[Musique]
j'adore la scène lantagne fumisterie
gens qui disent c'est une opération
commerciale encourager les gens à
dépenser de l'oseille connement j'ai
toujours aimé ça était ce un mal encore
valentine's day
[Musique]
c'est de l'avoir oublié et ses fils et
j'avais réservé un restaurant et j'avais
fait livrer un bouquet donc le bouquet
n'est jamais arrivé le matin la
réservation du restaurant a été annulé
on va dîner un côté pas de problème
c'est très bon indigestion dans la nuit
[Musique]
ah oui je suis un grand sentimental pour
moi l'émotion ça passe avant tout la
limite fleur bleue très mais pas la
samantha salas veulent maintenant je
vais être grossier
[Musique]
oui ah oui bien sûr que j'y crois je
gros coup de foudre jeu gros coup de
coeur
d'ailleurs sa mort est une femme
merveilleuse la dénommée oro allemann
mon chéri ça fait huit ans je les veux
j'ai dit toi tu seras
[Musique]
j'adore l'idée de donner un nom à une
étoile un truc du genre
un pressentiment parle quand même ce que
j'aime recevoir à saint valentin c'est
son amour décuplée par 3 troisième
partenaire à will always love you ceux
qui ont pas reconnu ces whitney houston
section elling marvin gaye sexuelle il
rit au nez la taupe
[Musique]
une miss france peut-être celui qui joue
khal drogo dans game of thrones
tellement c'est dans l'émission isabelle
en rémission naomi campbell préfet
réservé aux questions esthétiques en
amour mois au wynn tous amoureux donc
18h10 bon service amour toujours vers
sexuellement parlant du 17 on sent très
bien en toute modestie voilà sur 20 je
me mets un bon 14
j'ai un peu présomptueux est à moi tu ne
parles tendresse aaa
[Musique]